and here's the thing I love about you're
so normal when we were weird at the AMAs
you were hosting yeah and I was like oh
my god I love her I'm sitting or going
up and all the sudden I'm like why is
Diana Ross getting on stage with all her
family I was like I had no way this is
2017 like if this happened and I had no
I'm like a fan of you and I had no idea
I love that but thanks our career work
no you're so good you're so talented I
had no idea that it kind of made sense
the talent doesn't fall far from the
tree but that was like wow then I was
like you're so normal I would have never
guessed that you would have grown up in
Hollywood I would have never guessed you
grew up in Hollywood I grew up in my
mom's house okay and we weren't in
Hollywood we didn't we didn't live here
only when I was you weren't know and I
mean I was my mom is such a mom she's a
mom before she's anything else and so I
just had a really wait yeah I had like a
really regular upbringing a lot of
siblings you know I mean my mom was
always like this money is not for you
that's me I mean my kids are like wait
we have money I'm like no no no he's
like I'll pay for doctors and make sure
there's a roof over your head she'll a
certain point yeah and then go I'll pay
for health and education yeah nothing
else because you know what I turned out
just fine I didn't have anything I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this